you could definitely feel the love  between Nick Jonas and Priyanka Chopra  as the loved ones gather in Priyanka  Hong down to Mumbai for their impending  I Do's the bride-to-be was radiant in an  embroidered blue suit and sari while the  future groom donned an equally elaborate  pale pink traditional Indian outfit they  attended a pre-wedding dinner at the  home of Priyanka smother Nick's brother  Joe and his fiance sophie turner also  donned Indian clothing for the  pre-wedding gathering the weekend  wedding is rumoured to be held at an  elaborate palace in Joker India with 15  acres of lush gardens a source tells et  Nick understands how important it is to  Priyanka to stay true to her background  and wants her to have the best wedding  day and another Jonas appears to be  joining them  Nick's big brother Kevin posted this  smooch with wife Danielle on an airplane  so they could be heading to the wedding  [Music]